today on the matt wall show starring
best-selling children's author matt
walsh the supreme court here's a case
that very well could overturn
roe versus wade during arguments justice
sotomayor helpfully demonstrated the
scientific and moral vacuousness of the
pro-abortion side we'll look at that
today also my events at slu went forward
yesterday despite the mob of
protesters who stood outside blocking
traffic i tried to go out and talk to
them but they weren't really interested
in having a conversation and the
waukesha mass murderer complains that
he's being demonized for plowing his car
into a parade and killing six people
alec baldwin makes himself the victim in
his first interview since he shot and
killed a woman
on a movie set and australia hunts down
three teenagers who escaped a quarantine
camp finally our daily cancellation
we'll take a look at the worst christmas
comedy of all time which was just
released by hbo all of that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now a new sponsor on the show i'm
excited about the myq smart camera by
chamberlain did you know that
garages are the most frequently accessed
entry point for a home
often overlooked the garage is where the
people most important to you come and go
and it houses many of your most prized
possessions including your cars tools
bikes and so on so it's just common
sense to know what's going on inside
your garage
introducing the myq smart camera by
chamberlain the only smart camera
optimized for the garage
brought to you by the leaders in garage
door opener technology with features
like live video streaming recorded
events motion detection and two-way
communication right from your phone you
can make sure that your garage is secure
24 7. pair it with the myq smart garage
control and you'll never have to worry
if you left the garage door open again
you can check it see it and close it all
through the myq app
from anywhere and that's
one of the best features of this i think
is though because i'm definitely that
kind of person where you leave the house
and then you start thinking i shut the
garage i do this and that so you have
the ability to take care of all that on
your app so what are you waiting for
give the gift of a myq smart garage
camera to tech lovers this season if you
act now you can save 40 percent for a
limited time by entering walsh at
checkout on my q dot com slash walsh
that's walsh check out on my q dot com
slash walsh to say 40 keep an eye on
what's happening in and around your
home's busiest entryway with the my myq
smart garage camera it's the only smart
camera optimized for the garage so we
could very well be on the cusp of
history and for once i mean that
actually in a good way the supreme court
yesterday heard arguments in the dobbs
versus jackson women's health
organization cage case which stems from
a law in mississippi originally passed
in 2018 banning abortions after 15 weeks
setting the market at 15 weeks of course
directly challenges intentionally the
precedent set by the egregiously
terrible and evil road decision in 1973
which it's generally agreed requires
that abortion be allowed up until
viability
whatever exactly viability means
although the viability concept is
ambiguous most states say that the quote
unquote fetus is viable somewhere
between 20 and 24 weeks not 15 weeks
but again this whole way of speaking
about human children is
um doesn't make a lot of sense first of
all and is is already intentionally
dehumanizing what does it mean to say
that a human
is viable or not viable
what do you mean when you say that about
a human being most people would say that
viable fetus
means a baby who can survive outside the
womb but that's a misnomer and it also
shouldn't matter
right why should it matter
all healthy humans can survive
given the right environment
every single human being because we're
mortal creatures we have certain
environmental needs and if we if those
environmental needs are met we can
survive if they're not then we can't
for an unborn baby the environment they
require is a womb those of us on the
outside have different environmental
requirements so in order for a baby in
the womb to be viable
it must be able to survive in an
environment other than the one that it
naturally needs to be in
you might as well say that the only
viable adult is the one who can survive
on the moon or at the bottom of the sea
it doesn't make any sense
besides even the viable babies if
they're born early
will be sent up to the nicu like my like
the twins were our kids were that's what
happened with them because they were
born early
and they go to the nicu at the hospital
and they're put in an environment meant
to simulate a womb so a viable baby is
one who is in a simulated womb instead
of a natural one
the whole thing makes no sense
but i'm getting ahead of myself here i
think these are the sorts of issues they
debated yesterday relating to the dobbs
case
and the upshot is that potentially as
the mississippi law flies directly in
the face of roe and rightly so the
justices could come up with an opinion
that affirms the mississippi law and
overturns rope so we could be living in
the last days
of roe thank god
and the great thing is that even aside
from whatever decision
whatever the decision ultimately is
roe has already been exposed due to how
it was defended
by the liberal justices yesterday
there's a reason why the left would
prefer not to debate this topic at all
i mean they want to talk about this
topic
talk about it as in scream slogans in
your face
but they're not interested in a debate
because when they debate it you end up
with justice sotomayor who humiliated
herself repeatedly yesterday during the
deliberations
and exposed the pro-abortion side for
the vacuous poisonous nonsense that it
is case in point here she is claiming
that unborn children are brain dead
listen
virtually every state defines
a brain death as death
yet the literature is filled
with episodes of people who are
completely and utterly plain
responding to stimuli
it there's about 40 percent of dead
people
who if you touch their feet
the foot will recoil
there are spontaneous acts by dead brain
people
so i don't think
that a response
to
uh by a fetus necessarily proves
that there's a sensation of pain
or that there's consciousness
dead brained people is how she describes
a child in the womb
the problem is that the word dead
means literally no longer alive that's
what dead means that's the dictionary
definition
death it's also the medical definition
death is the stage you enter into after
your life is over
okay if sotomayor is suggesting that
unborn children are
dead from conception
then while they cannot be dead because
they were never alive according to her
by definition a thing which has never
been alive cannot be dead
the point is that if she believes that
the unborn child has never been alive
then she cannot say that it's dead by
definition
this of course leaves her with the major
problem of figuring out what sort of
state a person can be in where they are
neither dead nor alive
now we're in the realm of i don't know
vampires and zombies i suppose
the other point is that if unborn
children are dead
why do you need the abortion
the abortion is procured precisely to
cause the living child to become a dead
child if he's already a dead child what
role does the abortionist play
why are we even talking about this
and by the way how do we distinguish
between like a miscarriage and a healthy
child if they're all dead
when a pregnant woman goes in for her
appointments you know
throughout the pregnancy to get
sonograms and check on the child
uh to check out his health what are they
looking for how can they assess the
health of a dead creature
it's absurd and yet this is a supreme
court justice saying this
here's one other difference between an
unborn child and a dead person
the dead person will never not be dead
now i can't believe i have to explain
this to a supreme court justice but i do
so a dead person is is always going to
be dead at least at least from a
physical perspective in this life from a
scientific perspective death is final
dead people don't grow or develop into
living people
they don't grow or develop at all they
decompose and disintegrate
yet whatever you think of the unborn
child in the womb there is no question
that that if he is is healthy and left
alone in that environment he will be
born and become the sort of person that
even justice sotomayor would affirm as
living
justice sotomayor is a living person
right now herself
despite all appearances she is not
technically brain dead though maybe
perhaps close to it and yet justice
sotomayor was at one point an unborn
child if i would if i were to trace the
chain of sotomayor
and follow her back in time eventually i
would get to
the point where sotomayor was a baby in
the womb so there's an unbroken chain of
self-hood connecting the sotomayor of
today to the sotomayor in the womb
if she's a living person now she must
have been a living person then because
dead people don't become living people
it makes no logical or scientific sense
to say that any living person today was
at one point in their past a dead person
she also makes the claim that the unborn
child
isn't conscious
now she can't actually know if that's
true of course we don't understand
almost anything about consciousness what
it is where it comes from and in any
case why should life and consciousness
be conflated these are not the same
thing
who says that all living things must be
conscious
who decided that i mean technically
we technically we don't even know if
non-living things are unconscious
there's a whole branch of philosophy i
mean a fringe branch granted and silly
but but still called pan psychism which
claims that consciousness is a
fundamental fact of reality and that all
matter has some of some some amount of
consciousness
now that of course is almost certainly
not true my point is just that
consciousness is
um a philosophical discussion first of
all
not something the supreme court needs to
rule on but but also mysterious
we we just don't we don't know anything
about it
you can't use it to justify killing
babies or anybody
if consciousness is simply
self-awareness though the awareness that
you are a self the experience of being a
self if that's what consciousness is
then then perhaps the unborn child has
not yet developed that capacity
but then again the infant outside of the
womb doesn't have that capacity either
whatever the case however much
consciousness they do or don't have
what we know for sure is that it's a
temporary situation humans grow in
self-awareness as they get older and
develop are we saying that it's
permissible to kill temporarily
unconscious people
well that ought to make you pretty
uncomfortable when you go to sleep at
night
and lapse into a state of temporary
unconsciousness
it's all absurd it only gets worse from
there later sotomayor makes the claim
that the pro-life position is uh
entirely a religious position listen to
this
how is your interest anything but a
religious view
the issue of when life begins
has been hotly debated by philosophers
since the beginning of time
it's still debated in religions
so when you say this is the only right
that takes away from the state
the ability to protect the life
that's a religious view isn't it
because it assumes
that a fetus is life
at
when
you're not joined here when do you
suggest we begin that way
you're all right
aside from putting it aside from
religion
i i'll try to i think there might be
more than one question and i'll do my
very best justice sotomayor um i think
this court in gonzales pretty clearly
recognized that before viability we are
talking with unborn life with a human
organism and i think the philosophical
questions your honor mentioned all those
reasons that they're hard they've been
debated they're they're they're
important
those are all reasons to return this to
the people because the people should get
to debate these hard issues when does
the life of a woman
and putting her at risk
enter the calculus meaning
right now
forcing women who are poor and that's 75
percent of the population
and much higher percentage of those
women in mississippi
who elect abortions before viability
they are put at a tremendously greater
risk
of medical complications and ending
their life 14 times greater
to give birth to a child full term
than it is to have
an abortion before viability
on second thought she really is doing
quite a lot to prove that a person can
be alive but brain dead at the same time
i mean these arguments that she's
putting forward are about as
sophisticated as the kind of thing i
read from leftists in my youtube
comments
and we'll probably read after this show
she's just she's building a rhetorical
castle of of wrongness brick by brick
one wrong statement after another on top
of each other she says that the view
that fetuses are living
is religious
well no it's not it's science the
definition of life is literally the
condition that distinguishes animals and
plants from inorganic matter including
the capacity for growth reproduction
functional activity and continual change
preceding death
is the baby in the womb inorganic
is it an inanimate object
is it on the level of a rock or a chair
or a clump of dirt
if so how do i exist again i am a living
person and yet if i go back far enough
in my own timeline in the timeline of my
physical existence i will find myself as
a fetus quote unquote so was there a
time in my physical life
when i was not living
was there a stage of my life in which i
did not have life
that's not only scientifically
illiterate but it's logically
incomprehensible
and besides if the view that life begins
in the womb is religious
what about the view that life does not
begin in the womb
this is the bait and switch you always
get from these people they claim that
abort the abortion discussion
is a religious discussion yet and yet
yet somehow their own position within
that discussion is not religious somehow
nobody can know when life begins they
say
which means that our assurance that it
begins in the womb is a matter of faith
they say
and yet their assurance that it does not
begin in the womb is not faith
and anyway
if we don't know when life begins
right because that's their way around
this they're saying no i i'm not taking
a religious stance on this i bought we
don't know i so i'm saying i don't know
i'm being i'm not i've i'm agnostic on
when life begins that's basically what
sotomayor was saying
okay so if we don't know when life
begins as she says
isn't that all the more reason not to
kill children in the womb
she says we don't know but but what that
actually means is i don't know right
she's saying that she doesn't know she
can't speak for what other people know
or don't know
she could only say what she doesn't know
and so she admits that she doesn't know
if life begins in the womb yet she wants
to kill them anyway
even though there is
according to her by her own confession
at least a chance that the child is
alive
so she's willing to say yeah 60 million
kids have been aborted since roe v wade
well according to her there's at least a
chance that all 60 million were human
beings and that and that we have
committed a genocide of 60 million
babies there's a chance of that
according to her
so isn't that like throwing a grenade
into a into a dark room
hoping and assuming the room is empty
but not knowing for sure
if you kill someone
in the process of doing that even if you
didn't know you didn't know there was
someone in the room but you knew they
could have been in the room
and you threw it anyway are you guilty
of of of murder yes
see it's the pro-abortion side which
truly acts on faith here theirs is a
religious conviction
roe v wade was a decision which imposed
the leftist religious view
with abortion as its highest sacrament
on to the entire nation
they're not defending a medical
procedure they're defending their sacred
ritual and it's impossible to fathom
therefore
just the demonic fury that will erupt
from these people
should roe be overturned
and that is a spectacle that we will all
get to witness very soon god willing
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as we get towards christmas if
you're panicking and thinking like what
can i get someone for christmas i need i
need a good i need a gift i need a gift
that's uh that's thoughtful and that
won't look like i came up with it at the
last minute let me give you an idea
paintyourlife.com paintlife.com will can
get you an original painting by a
world-class artist done by hand from any
photo at an affordable price
you can get a professional hand painted
portrait created from any photo and
again the prices are very very
affordable you could sit well all you
have to do it's very easy i've done done
this a couple of times you send them any
picture whether it's a picture of
yourself your children family a special
place a moment on vacation whatever a
pet and you can you can even combine
photos into one painting and make an
original image that way
and with paint your life's compilation
portraits you can bring together family
members who never had the chance to meet
or create a portrait of the whole family
without the need for everyone to be
there for a family photo
and then all they're going to do is
they're going to have their team of
world class artists
turn this into a painting and you're
going to be very involved every step of
the way and they're going to turn that
thing around and get it back to you much
quicker than you can possibly imagine at
paintylife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed and right now as
a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that's right 20 off and free
shipping to get the special offer text
the word matt to sixty four thousand
that's matt to sixty four thousand text
matt to sixty four thousand paint your
life celebrate the moments that matter
most well as we get into uh into news i
should
mention because i think i've neglected
to mention this probably all week but i
do have a children's book out called
johnny the walrus and that's this if
you're wondering where this book is
sitting right here next to me and you're
watching this um that's my book johnny
the walrus and it is on sale at
johnthewalrus.com right now
uh just to be totally honest and
transparent with you
we had no i
we didn't expect the book to be
quite as popular as it has been so we
sold out of them in less than a day
which i don't think anyone was quite
prepared for now i knew it would be a
smash success but even i wasn't quite
prepared for that which is why if you go
to amazon right now you still won't find
the book uh we are solving we're in the
process of solving that problem and
hopefully sometime today will be
available on amazon again until they ban
it but um
as we're getting you know as we're
getting kind of restocked here um but
you can still reserve your copy at
johnnythewalrus.com
today okay
one other thing on the supreme court
case that i wanted to mention um
pulling this up from fox news uh talk we
talk about the the demonic fury of the
pro-abortion side well speaking of which
fox news reports
protesters gathered outside the supreme
court
were seen taking abortion pills ahead of
the nation's uh high the nation's
highest court hearing arguments over the
mississippi law challenging roe v wade
abortion pills forever the protesters
repeatedly chanted according to footage
posted by aaron matson on twitter
wednesday morning
and then they um
in fact we have the video they uh they
were out there chanting
it's standing in front of a sign that
says we are taking abortion pills
forever
and then there were four women who pull
out a pill and take it let's play that
video
[Applause]
[Applause]
forever there we go
now this is evidence again that the safe
legal and rare days are long behind us i
mean long behind us they've been behind
us for uh for a while
really really the personhood debates are
behind us also at least culturally
uh it's still worth
having the discussion
especially because in the supreme court
you know this this is
the that case is going to center around
questions like personhood but in the
culture anyway the pro-abortion side you
know they don't care if the baby is a
baby or not
if the baby is living or not
they've moved they've moved beyond that
they've moved past that
doesn't matter to them the shout your
abortion these were all the uh hashtag
shout your abortion people out there the
shout your abortion people
when they're shouting their abortion
they're not saying um oh i i got an
abortion because
my my
the fetus isn't conscious
or i got an abortion because i don't
believe that life begins at conception
that's not what they're saying they're
saying i got an abortion because i
wanted to
i got abortion because it's my body and
i'll do what i want with it
and if that means killing a child then
so be it
that's the attitude
the point is that the self reigns
supreme
and the woman as
herself
should be able to do whatever she wants
also the pro boards see the relationship
between a mother and child as as
fundamentally antagonistic
and so it's it's sort of like an us or
them mentality that they have about
children
there's a very there's very real anger
among pro boards at babies themselves we
we could call them
and we could without hyperbole we could
call them anti-baby because of course
they are it's no surprise given that
they support killing millions of babies
um but they actually they actually hate
babies
the very existence of children they hate
they hate children
because children are dependent on
parents dependent on mothers
and they hate that
the idea that anybody would be dependent
on them
the idea that anybody would make any
kind of claim over them
the idea that they would be responsible
to anyone
for anything they can't abide but abide
that
in their self-worshiping
literally satanic religion they can't
abide them
they see family life as a zero-sum game
you know it's it's a competition
this is why feminists
if anyone makes the catastrophic mistake
of marrying a feminist they never stay
married for very long
i think the the world record for the
longest feminist marriage is um is three
and a half years i believe let's check
guinness but it's not it's not gonna
last for very long
because they see the family as a
patriarchal institution they see it as
as it's all competition
it's me or you
this is a this is a struggle between
mother and child mother and father
and um
that's why just doesn't that's why
marriages don't work but that's that's
also why as far as they're concerned
yeah sit there take a take an abortion
pill
safe legal and rare i mean
sure we want abortions to be legal but
rare why should abortions be rare
abortions are an expression of a woman's
uh independence her autonomy
they should happen more often if
anything that's the attitude
all right uh after all the hype and
build up and in spite of the many
obstacles putting our way our event at
slu happened last night or slu which is
apparently what the students call it and
they didn't tell me that until the q a
and i was calling it slu the entire time
um but i'm just gonna stick with slu
anyway
enormous crowds we had a room with a
capacity of 200 people i think we fit
450 people into it
plus plus plus an overflow room so it
was great and then of course there was
the mob of protesters outside blocking
traffic
i did decide to go outside and um
confront the protesters personally
not confront i wanted to go i wanted to
talk to them have a conversation
and also give them a chance to answer
the what is a woman question because
that was my challenge
i did say that before i came on campus i
said if anyone can come
to my talk and and define if any
leftists can come and define the word
woman and do it successfully i will
admit defeat and i will never speak on
another college campus ever again
and um none of them actually showed up
to the talk to to meet my my challenge
so i went out to them and um
uh not you know is it necessarily a
smart or safe thing to go out to go walk
out into the middle of the street and
talk to the angry mob of insane people
who've come to protest you
probably not but i don't often choose
the uh the smart path so no reason to
start now i figure but rather than me
recapping it i'll play this report from
cbs which which is actually surprisingly
fair they were there and they captured
some of this including
uh me and my my uh i suppose
conversation with protesters let's let's
watch that
a conservative speaker's views sparking
protest tonight st louis university
students invited matt walsh to speak
he's a commentator for the conservative
media outlet the daily wire news 4's
caroline hecker was there as the clash
of opinions hit the streets of midtown
a clash of views
outside the coronado near slough's
campus wednesday night ahead of the
arrival of conservative speaker matt
walsh
but the controversy began weeks ago
walsh was originally scheduled to speak
at a building on campus but says the
university's coveted measures were too
strict saint francis xavier church also
on campus then volunteered to play host
but the president of slu's college
republicans says at the last minute the
priest changed his mind we're very
disappointed to see that the church
would rescind the invitation especially
on such short notice father dan white
released this statement claiming
comments made by walsh quote run
contrary to the values of catholic faith
resulting in the event being cancelled
but that's just not true matt is a
devout catholic
his views
are in like
very good alignment with the church
students then secured an off-campus
location drawing long lines wednesday
night
before the speech walsh came outside to
speak with the protesters who accuse him
of being racist and transphobic those
inside say while they don't expect
everyone to agree civil discourse is
important i don't think matt walsh is
some kind of extremist or anything like
that i think he's pretty normal and
mainstream in the conservative media so
i think it's very very important for you
know colleges to accept that
even they may not agree i still think
that the first amendment's pretty
important and it's very important for
students to be able to you know hear
from a different perspective we spoke
with dozens of slu students before the
event started who were waiting in line
none of them wanted to talk to us on
camera telling me they were fearful that
giving their opinions could make them a
target on campus
well what does that tell you probably
the most revealing thing in the whole
thing they were there they'd want to be
on camera talking about it because
and can you blame them given given where
they're going to school
the kind of treatment i got and the
great thing for me is that i can show up
and cause a lot of trouble and then
leave
but they have to
stay there on campus so i give a lot of
credit to students who
made this
just
no matter what they they were going to
make this event happen and so a lot of
credit to them for doing that
why did i go out there to talk to them
well for one thing it's only polite to
go and say hi to people that have come
out you know because of you
and for another these people are cowards
um
and we are far too often intimidated by
cowards
when because they're in large groups
you know individually they're they're
they won't even show up
none of those people not not one single
person from that crowd went inside
certainly to hear the talk or or to they
had a chance in the q a you can take the
microphone
and if you think that you can embarrass
me
by exposing my ideas as being bigoted
and all that kind of stuff
why not take that why not take that
opportunity
if i'm really if i'm really just a
raging bigot a stupid raging bigot well
that should be very easy to
uncover in a conversation where you have
a microphone
but they're not going to do that because
then it's one on one
and they don't want to be in that kind
of position um they always want to they
always want to operate in groups
and when they all come together we put
put a bunch of cows together
together in a group people become
intimidated
and we cannot be intimidated
so yeah i'll just go right out there and
talk what are they gonna do
i was walking up i don't know if it was
caught we actually we have footage
ourselves that we um
that we took and i put it up some of
them up on twitter i'll put it up on
instagram also and i think you it
captures this moment where i'm walking
up to the crowd
and uh one of the guys comes comes
forward and says screams do not come
over here and then so i came over there
and he just backed away
so pretty pretty great and as i was
standing there also it was fun to watch
because the crowd was originally in the
street blocking traffic but as i was
standing there they all started backing
away and then very soon we're off of the
street
so it's just me and like
200 people
and they're afraid is that because i'm a
big bad wolf i'm big and scary no
just because they're absolute cowards
and they're and they're not ready to be
challenged and not expecting it
and don't know what to do when they are
um and they have a fragile this this
worldview that they've constructed
and that they have
subscribed to is very very fragile
and it cannot withstand
any inspection
any cross-examination
so that was good
although i will say one other one other
note about this is that um
the talk almost
didn't happen at all not for the reasons
that you've heard about but um
i will admit that we were we were flying
out of dc to go to st louis
and somehow we ended up going to the
wrong airport
um and so i own i we we almost missed
the flight i was at the wrong airport we
went to dulles we're supposed to be at
reagan
and uh we had like 45 minutes to get
over the airport get get through
security and i almost missed the flight
i'm just thinking
my god after all of this if the talk is
shut down because i had to cancel it
because i went to the wrong airport then
missed my flight
that
that that would be
that would be the one way to for me to
pull an hell out of this whole situation
but thankfully that that didn't happen
all right let's go to um
this from fox 6 assist
has spent the last 10 days locked up in
a wisconsin jail cell
after allegedly mowing down uh through
the barricades and into revelers at the
waukesha christmas parade killing six
people
now he feels dehumanized he told fox
news digital wednesday
in his first remarks to the media
seemingly surprised that he had visitors
39 said i just feel like i'm being a
monster demonized
wearing a sleeveless green jail jumpsuit
and his hair in braids the soft-spoken
accused killer offered no details about
what prompted the carnage
the two fox news reporters on the other
side of the video screen marked the
first visitors he's seen since the
november 21st night of horror not even
his mother has dropped by he said
so he's complaining that he's being
dehumanized and demonized
well he's actually right that he has
been dehumanized and demonized the only
difference is that um the only only he's
just wrong
about who is responsible for doing that
see he has dehumanized and demonized
himself
in a very literal sense
he has decided through his own actions
to sink below the level of a human being
to act like an animal
to become a demon
so that's that's that's you doing that
that's the decision you made not the
rest of us
it's also interesting that
they were able to talk to him
um for a couple minutes
and so he is he is talking to the media
the one the one media outlet interested
in talking to him of course fox news
but we we still have not been told
anything about why he did it
i think we know why he did it
but even though this this uh this
scumbag this animal this monster is
still alive
and it's talking
we still don't know why he did it
speaking of his mom
this is also from fox it says daryl
brooks's mother broke her silence
wednesday at a letter to the media
blaming last month's christmas parade
tragedy on a lack of mental health
services for her son according to a
press report
brooks was living with his 62 year old
mom big surprise when authorities say he
plowed his red ford escape into an
annual christmas parade
um
we are not making excuses woods wrote a
letter but we believe that what has
happened is because he was not given the
help and resources he need needs
institutions that are equipped and have
trained staff is what we is needed as
well as resources in the communities
where people who suffer with mental
illnesses live
jail is not the answer because they get
released back in society sicker than
they were before when they entered
we all see what a tragedy that can turn
out to be
well
again she's she's partially read
jail is not the answer for violent
dangerous people
if you're just going to release them
again
in a couple of months or a couple of
years so she's right about that the
answer though is um is not to
not send them to jail at all but to send
them to jail and keep them there that
would that would have been the answer
with with daryl brooks
but i totally agree with her that
you take uh an evil person or as she
would put it mentally ill a
quote-unquote sick person
um and you put them in jail you you kind
of filter them through the system
letting them marinate
for a short period of time in an
environment with other violent
psychopaths
and then you release them back
and and tell them make sure to check in
with your parole officer every once in a
while
you do that and you are asking for
something like this
you're practically inviting it
explicitly
but the answer again is to no you send
them to jail and you keep them there
what she's doing here and she has the
incentive of making an excuse for her
son um she's not the only one who does
this
but this this medicalization of human
evil
even people who are not related to mass
killers will very often say they'll look
at something like this when it happens
whether it's waukesha or uh you know the
oxford high school shooting a few days
after that
and we say well this they must have been
crazy
there's there's no way a sane person
would do this
and then pretty soon you end up in a
situation where evil doesn't exist
anymore as a category of human behavior
there is no evil anymore there are um
good people
who basically do the right thing most of
the time
and then there are crazy people and
those are the two categories
now this is this is great for the
pharmaceutical industry
this is great for the psychology
industry
psychiatric industry it's great for them
all that means is that we are farming
all of these problems out to
uh doctors and psychiatrists and pills
to solve
but psychiatrists and doctors and pills
cannot solve the problem of human evil
no no human institution can solve that
problem
now i understand why we want to retreat
behind this medicalization reflex
because it's a it's a scary thing to
think it's a scary thought
that sane lucid people could make the
choice
to do something like what this guy did
it's a scary thought but but that's the
reality of human
nature uh finally on waukesha a few days
ago ron desantis spoke some truth on on
the subject and i thought this was great
let's let's listen to this
is that how it works the suvs they just
drive by themselves this just kind of
happened and they say oh this was a big
accident you never actually hear
the discussion about who committed this
what was the motivation
this guy was a career criminal let out
on didn't really have any bail basically
should not have even been on the street
had clear
anti-white animus
and this was an intentional act and it
seems like you know for corporate press
they're more apt to characterize a
parent who goes to a school board
meeting to protest bad policies as a
domestic terrorist than somebody who
intentionally rams an suv
into a crowd of innocent people so you
have at least six have died you have
many more that have been injured i know
many people are in the hospital and so
uh let's just be clear this was not a
car just driving in this was an attack
by a felon who did that who should not
have been on the street and we'll see
what the actual motivation was it very
well may have been in response to what
happened with kyle rittenhouse and you
have to wonder if that's the case
almost surely this guy's view of written
house was was colored by all these media
lies
rhonda sanders very effective governor
but uh in terms of criticizing the media
and exposing the media there is no
republican in elected office
or formerly an elected office
who is as effective and eloquent and
powerful in that regard as ronnie
sanders
so
i think he's he's the best in the
republican party he's the best at
governing right now
he's also the best
at criticizing the media if we consider
that to be an important
aspect of of you know being a republican
elected leader and i do think it's
actually pretty important
um
he put it very well there in about in
about one minute i don't think there's
anyone else in the republican party
who's doing that
all right australia has been putting
people in camps quarantine camps and
there's been a lot of discussion about
this on social media
with some people insisting that sure
they're shipping people off to camps and
sure that has some really problematic
historical implications but but but
social media has also said it's all
voluntary you understand
they're volunteering to go to these
camps
well here's a report out of australia
and you tell me if this sounds
voluntary to you
teenagers who allegedly escaped
quarantine at the howard springs
facility near darwin have been taken in
by police following a six-hour search
nine's italia saw has the latest for us
well we can expect to see some changes
implemented here at the center for
national resilience after three
teenagers allegedly escaped a search
spanning several hours was sparked this
morning after police say the group
scaled the fence and fled howard springs
around 4 30 am authorities located the
teenagers about half a dozen kilometres
away it's understood they traveled by
foot and didn't mingle with anyone else
the 15 16 and 17 year old are close
contacts of a case from the remote
community of binjari near catherine who
all tested negative to covert yesterday
the territory's police commissioner
believes isolation and loneliness may
have contributed to the trio taking off
empathising they're not used to living
in their own units cctv will also now be
increased across the site as well as
bolstered internal security the trio are
expected to face a fine of five grand
each
oh you think that might be what it is
isolation and loneliness you think maybe
yeah they think
maybe when you take um
innocent people who haven't committed a
crime and you put them in solitary
confinement in a camp out in the
wilderness
well gosh
man i
i don't know why they would try to
escape but could it be that they're a
little bit lonely and isolated
then we and and we put them in this
miserable condition and taking away all
their freedoms
with no justification
by the police they're they're
speculating that that might be what it
is
did i hear that right by the way they
tested negative
so
these people are not sick
even if they were sick
you know i'm not in favor of rounding up
sick people and sending them to camps
either
but it's all the worst when these are
not sick people
so they they they allegedly had contact
with someone who might have had covet
they didn't get sick they tested
negative and yet they were put in
isolation camps
this is happening in in this in the
supposedly civilized world
in australia which may be far away
geographically but culturally it's not
by the way quarantine
i know we've gotten used to this term
quarantine
but quarantine is for sick people by
definition
no the
quarantine is what you do with a sick
person
when you take a healthy person
who is not sick and has not committed a
crime and you lock them in a you lock
them anywhere
and restrict their freedom of movement
so much so that if they leave wherever
you put them
we call it an escape and you chase them
down with dogs and spotlights and
helicopters
um that's uh that's not called
quarantine
you know that's false imprisonment
that's kidnapping
and if you're doing this in a camp
where you were bringing concentrations
of people
who are not sick and have not committed
a crime and you're putting them in a
camp and telling them they can't leave
i mean there there are lots of different
words we could use
labels that we could put on that
and as i said they all have uh
very very terrifying historical
implications
so this is what's happening again in the
supposedly civilized world
all right
let's hop over i got to play this for
you before we get into uh the comment
section
a little bonus content here let's
because we're already in australia let's
just hop over to uh new zealand
where some misguided white people have
produced something
truly horrific and this is another one
of those occasions where i
i was subjected to this
misery loves company and so now i'm
forcing you to see it too uh here it is
and academics who are usually hard at
work behind the scenes have been given
center stage during the pandemic they've
become the faces of covert sharing their
expertise as we seek more information to
combat the misinformation now a familiar
face is using his science skills to
strike a new chord
[Music]
but here's the issue and it's quite
severe we need everyone in or the result
is clear the virus will loiter outside
your home try to steal your breath in
fact you don't if everyone is keen to go
and get the vac you're gonna be safe in
the face of virus attacks defend
ourselves from no mutations
[Music]
the nation vaccinate the nation vast the
nation
[Music]
so
there's that
but we'll get to the comment section
[Music]
well now that thanksgiving is over it's
time for the holidays and this is when
you start reminiscing on the past and
all of your great memories but the
problem is
that a lot of those memories that you
have of the past they are
locked inside antiquated technology that
um you may not have the ability to even
access anymore and can easily be
destroyed you got it you have it stored
somewhere in an attic or in a basement
susceptible to flooding and just the
ravages of time that's why you need
legacy bucks
and right now legacy box has their cyber
week sale where you can take an unreal
65
off legacy box is the simple and safe
way to preserve your irreplaceable
family memories their service couldn't
be easier you send in your legacy box
filled with old home movies and photos
and they will get to work creating a
digital collection stored on a thumb
drive dvd or the cloud plus with their
cyber week sale you can have everything
preserved at a fraction of the regular
price everything is professionally
digitized and um
in look over a million people have taken
advantage of this service and so you
know that it's good legacy boxes cyber
week sale is here and they're giving our
listeners the best deal of the year
visit
legacybox.com walls for an incredible 65
off any size legacy box that's
legacybox.com slash walsh for 65 off
don't wait this deal won't last long
legacy box dot com slash walsh
um
khan dervis says if this is a catholic
school i cannot imagine the situation in
a normal school
parents save your children before it's
too late
uh yeah it's if you needed another
wake-up call about the university system
then maybe that's one this is allegedly
a catholic school and that's a
i cannot
i have of course talked we've talked
about it plenty over the last few weeks
but i still cannot fully
put into words
uh how depressing it is although you try
to have some fun with it as i did last
night it's still
supremely depressing
as a catholic
that the most hostile reception i've
ever received on any campus is at a
catholic school
i've never had anything like that
i mean there's been plenty of campuses
i've gone to where there's been some
protests and they've put petitions and
they didn't want me to come
but nothing to that level
i mean there were hundreds of people
outside blocking traffic that's how
upset they were on top of everything
else they did before
i showed up at a catholic school the
worst the worst at a catholic school
i've gone to um
i mean we we've gone to you know public
universities in california we've been
we've gone all over the place we've gone
to very very liberal schools
and uh it wasn't that bad in fact the
other
the second
most hostile reception was that uh was
at baylor so
you know
the christian catholic schools
at least in terms of of this and how
they receive conservative speakers in my
experience are the worst
what does that tell you
all right uh devin says as a bestselling
children's author you need to be careful
who's in charge of the books when you
die
you can't let them get canceled like dr
seuss well i've already been canceled so
that's a that's a move point plus
all my books are going to be buried with
me when i die
all the remaining books
all the books that have already been
sold
that's my
that's that's the ritual that's going to
be in my my my request upon my death
i'll be buried and then everyone who's
bought who has previously purchased
johnny the walrus come to my funeral and
throw
it in to the hole with me to be buried
with me
it's a little strange but that's that's
my tradition
uh let's see
uh what do we got
derek says just ordered the spg camp mug
and johnny the walrus soon i'll be dad
level 1000 and my kids won't have any
idea what hit them
um yes well that's
as as i don't know if i mentioned yet
but if you wanted to purchase johnny
walrus right now the only place you can
do it is by going to uh
dailywire.com and while you're there at
the shop dailywire.com at the uh the
merch store or the swag shack you might
as well pick up we got a whole lot of
johnny the walrus merchandise as well
along with our shop or rather our return
or die shopping cart t-shirt which is
still my favorite item that we have
there all of the anti-panda merchandise
all of it's there at delhi.com
kyle says i'm slowly beginning to think
that matt truly does enjoy talking about
refinancing and mortgages i don't even
think he's getting paid to promote
american financing any longer your
intuition intuition is actually correct
i told them to stop paying me for it i
couldn't accept money for something that
brings me such joy so you're right about
that
um matt did you get the idea for johnny
the walrus from the movie tusk
just kidding but i'd like to see your
critique on some of kevin smith's movies
your description of the tsa
really was a good comparison to how
humans can easily become tyrants with a
tiny bit of power given
no i i
i heard about this tusk movie after
johnny the walrus came out and everybody
started telling me this is like tusk
and um
now that i've had the movie described to
me it sounds horrifying and also
pointless
not exactly the same thing as john
johnny the walrus
actually
i got the i the walrus idea specifically
and i didn't get it from the beatles
either
um i got it from my wife the truth is
i'm proud to say my wife helped me come
up with this idea so she first suggested
to me the idea this was back like in the
winter last winter she suggested to me
the idea that i should write a
children's book
and um the original concept was a
children's book that would be in true
you know
in true matt welsh style i suppose uh
just dark and depressing and that was
originally the idea and then we kind of
started thinking about it more and then
i threw out the idea of the trans book
idea
and we were thinking about well what
animal should should the kid be and then
my wife had the moment of inspiration
walrus
it's just the funniest animal for the
for these purposes and she's right so um
that's how that all came about
and
uh finally bob says matt walsh literally
got me interested in christ then he
admits that he's a banjo fraud on tim
cast
you broke my heart matt walsh glad i'm
banned
i i did say that
on on the show that i didn't know how to
play the banjo but that was more you
know
there were a lot of musicians in the
room and i don't want to embarrass them
with my own musical
abilities so i i said that i didn't know
how to play it but i was that was
humility on my part okay don't blame me
for humility well as you've heard as a
newly crowned best-selling children's
author in fact i think i could call
myself at least for a day um the
top-selling children's author in the
world
um and in fact the johnny the walrus was
so popular that we were not able to keep
it on the shelves we sold out in less
than a day and so that means that if you
want to get your copy of johnny lawrence
as long as as well as 10 other copies to
give to all your family and friends
especially the more left-leaning family
and f and friends um then you got to go
to johnnywalrus.com
and reserve a copy today and you could
do that also i got to let you know that
the daily wire has been hard at work
keeping their promise of bringing you
tons of content that you literally won't
get anywhere else like
johnny the walrus that's not what this
promo is about
and we're so excited to share one of our
highly anticipated trailers with you the
trailer features our first original
production shut-in a seat gripping
thriller that'll be available to stream
in early 2022. the film follows the
story of a young mother who is
barricaded inside a closet by her
violent ex-husband and she's trapped
inside as she's trapped inside she uses
nothing but her voice to guide her
children on the other side of the walls
to safety all while the threat of her
danger
um of the danger looms and we just
released the trailer we'll play it now
so it's a very effective trailer uh
let's watch that
laney
[Music]
where have you been
[Music]
going away
i'm gonna take off tonight so the kids
can sleep most of the way
[Music]
well i'm mostly done i just need to
finish cleaning out the pantry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please let me out please
lady
[Music]
your daughter she's very pretty don't
you touch
my kids
rob owes me money there's money there's
a lot of money there's thousands of
dollars in the pantry have it all
please come on i'm scared
well if you want to go see the full
trailer that's just a teaser head to the
daily wires youtube channel to get an
even better idea of just how explosive
this film is going to be we seriously
cannot wait to share the finished
product with you if you're planning on
adding this terrifying thriller to your
queue in 2022 and you want us to keep
making content to combat the over
politicized mainstream entertainment
sector well then you've gotta subscribe
become a subscriber today
and also go check out the trailer and
make sure you share it uh on your social
media pages as well now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so today's cancellation is something of
a layup i suppose here's here's a just a
thing that's begging to be canceled seth
rogen and sarah silverman are starring
in an animated christmas themed
miniseries called santa inc
which was just released today on hbo max
um i i will play some of the preview for
you but you probably don't need to see
it because all you have to do is imagine
in your head
what a woke animated r-rated christmas
show starring seth rogen and sarah
silverman might look and sound like
and what you're imagining in your head
is exactly what hbo has provided us
uh now that you've already imagined it
and i played it it'll be it'll feel a
little bit like deja vu i suppose but
but here it is
when you're a kid there's only one day a
year more special than any other day
and that day is christmas
and we are the magic behind that day
so let's get these [ __ ] kids some
[ __ ]
may i present the hardest working man in
snow biz good golly he's jolly our own
santa claus
hey merry christmas whoa
you're on my naughty list
[Music]
good news sir more american kids believe
in you than they do in vaccines or the
holocaust that's great i mean
disheartening for america but great for
us
i'm here from the north pole times have
you decided who will succeed you with
santa claus subtext santa's old and
knocking on death's door
uh i mean uh that good good question
i'll give it some serious thought
bye
there have been many santa clauses
throughout history some were loved
others loathed but the position of santa
has mostly been a white man's game
exactly it's [ __ ] crazy things have
got to change my advice to you is wow
if i die get rid of my porn
i want to be the next santa if this is
your dream you have to at least make
your case you gotta get intimate with
that jolly
that was without exaggeration one of the
worst previews i've ever seen in my life
for anything ever
and i didn't even play the worst parts
because there's another 45 seconds or so
where we learn more about how santa is
bad because he's white and male
and what we really need is a non-white
non-male santa
also a non-christian santa would seem
it probably didn't escape your notice
that the lead actors in this christmas
show
are not christian
now that wouldn't be a problem except
that the show is making fun of christmas
and was obviously produced by people who
have real animosity towards christmas
traditions
one can only imagine the response if
christian actors start in a film making
fun of islamic customs for example
in fact even if christian actors started
a film paying tribute to islam
and saying nice things about it
it would still be considered offensive
and appropriative
and yet non-christian actors can star in
films mocking christmas and that's
perfectly acceptable
but that's far from the worst part of
this
what we really see is why and how
comedy has died in our country
no i i personally can forgive almost any
sin that comedy commits as long as it's
still funny
that that's my position the the the job
of comedy is to be funny after all and
so i'm somewhat of a machiavellian ends
justify the means type when it comes to
comedy as long as you're making me laugh
i'm not all that worried about how you
do it because i figure that's the job
here that's what you're supposed to be
doing just make your comedy funny and
that's all i ask we'll sort the other
details out later
and yet this this fundamental
requirement is too onerous for most
comedies these days in this show
it seems that most of the laughs are
supposed to come from the fact that the
characters are cursing
the show is very impressed with its own
vulgarity
it's so it's vulgar just for the sake of
being vulgar the very first punchline is
that an elf says the f word that's like
the only punch line in the whole preview
is that all the characters oh they're
they're cussing and they're cartoons
and they go back to that well time and
again look an elf is cussing look now
santa is cussing look now reindeer is
cussing
just wait till you hear the first uh you
hear frosty the snowman he's gonna cuss
too
it's lazy and it's boring and it's
childish comedies these days are often
lazy boring and childish also we have
the woke factor of course
and woke isn't funny because for one
thing there's nothing amusing about
being preached at
in a certain context it might be kind of
funny to watch a feminist screech about
the patriarchy or whatever i mean i was
amused by the feminists protesting my
event last night and screeching at me
but that's not the kind of amusement you
want to derive from a comedy
and most importantly on top of being
irritating and self-righteous and
fundamentally humorous
woke also represents the mainstream
position
the position held by the powerful and
the elite
comedy especially a vulgar r-rated
comedy should be transgressive and edgy
it should challenge the mainstream
perspective
it should desecrate the sacred cows
comedy when it comes when it when it
performs this task
is actually playing an important role in
society i think but most comedy today is
propaganda on behalf
of the elites of the ruling class
that's why when i watch snl for like the
90 seconds i can stomach it every six
months or so
i get the sense that i'm watching
like sketch comedy in north korea or
something it's probably very similar
there
propaganda with bad punch lines and
forced laughter and finally this show
like so much comedy today
um isn't funny because it's too angry to
be funny
it's it's resentful
it's perfectly possible to make a
christmas comedy that pokes fun at
christmas traditions
and also manages to be very funny
many such comedies exist a christmas
story is an all-time classic in that
genre but that requires you to have some
kind of understanding of
and affection for the thing that you're
lampooning if you hate it
then all you'll end up making is a
disgruntled diatribe not a comedy
and that's what this is
that's why everybody associated with
this crime against comedy and against
humanity
is of course today cancelled
and those of you who have not gone to
dailywire.com and or rather
johnnywalrus.com is the quickest way to
get there those of you have not gone to
johnnywalrus.com and purchased a book
johnny walrus you are also canceled
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
the supreme court might overrule roe
versus wade some australians escape from
a quarantine camp and dr oz runs for
senate check it out on the michael
knowles show